républicain il y a tout juste six mois
et déjà notre média est lancé et déjà
notre école de formation est lancée et
déjà nous lançons cette magnifique
notre renoi il l'avait promis durant sa
campagne et nous dit ça vous le
connaissez
Eric et coueux
Eric et passionné
Eric et
tenard il a affronté la tempête des
retraites et il a tenu bon jusqu'au bout
car c'est un combattant il se bat pour
assembler notre famille politique il se
bat pour remettre notre partie au
travail il se bat pour que nos revenions
à l'Elysée en 2027 oui alors mes amis
avec lui battons-nous pour sortir la
France du gouffre la route sera longue
mais ensemble portez pas notre amour de
la France nous y parviendrons alors
apportez votre énergie au Républicain
donnez votre force à celui qui a fait
sienne la devise du Maréchal Foch ma
droite est enfoncée ma gauche a céder
situation excellente Janak alors
applaudissez faites bondissez vos
drapeaux et ensemble attaquons
dressez-vous partons à la conquête de la
France
applaudissez Éric Ciotti
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compagnons oui mes chers
compagnons rien que c'est beau Renou
avec nos racines
mes chers amis quel bonheur de vous
retrouver ce matin merci à vous d'avoir
répondu à l'appel de la fidélité
merci à vous tous militants des
républicains mais surtout militant de la
France
il nous disait bon diviser il nous
disait dépasser
pourtant nous voici pourtant nous sommes
là vivant et rassemblés c'est cette
fidélité qui nous permet aujourd'hui de
lancer nos états généraux
nous entrons aujourd'hui plus résolu que
jamais sur le chemin de notre
refondation
au fil des mois nous réunirons toutes
nos fédérations militants élues
intellectuelles pour débattre échanger
nous voulons nous ouvrir au plus grand
nombre nous mènerons dans cet esprit une
vaste consultation où chacun pourra
librement participer contribuer
vous l'avez compris ces états généraux
ne sont pas l'affaire d'un seul jour
ils ouvrent un long chemin
un long chemin qui nous mènera de débats
en discussion de rencontre en réflexion
de ce jour jusqu'au début de l'année
ces rendez-vous se veulent être ceux de
la vérité
et de la lucidité
disons-le d'emblée notre famille
politique n'a pas manqué d'être bousculé
fragiliser
installant le doute jusqu'à notre avenir
au milieu de vous je suis un militant
parmi les militants
[Applaudissements]
j'ai adhéré au RPR en 1981
animé des mêmes espoirs
ayant goûté l'enthousiasme des mêmes
victoires
mais aussi ayant connu le désarroi des
belles défaites
un militant qui comme vous ne veut pas
se résigner
se résigner à voir notre famille
politique jouer les seconds rôles ou les
supplétifs des uns ou des autres
la seule place qui vaille mes amis vous
le savez pour nous c'est la première la
seule boussole
[Applaudissements]
la seule boussole qui doit nous guider
c'est l'intérêt de la France
indépendant comme le souligné le
président Larcher
est libre toujours
indépendant et libre
la figuration
la figuration très peu pour nous
très peu pour nous qui avons fondé aux
côtés du général de Gaulle la Cinquième
République très peu pour nous qui avons
tant apporté à la France de Georges
Pompidou à Nicolas Sarkozy de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing
je suis un militant
auquel vous avez fait l'honneur de
confier la présidente de notre mouvement
le 11 décembre dernier
après un beau débat
respectueux de qualité avec Bruno
retaillot et Aurélien Pradier que je
salue et que je veux remercier
[Applaudissements]
merci à toi Bruno merci à toi Aurélien
votre présence votre présence et le
signe que nous sommes unis et rassemblés
pour l'essentiel depuis que vous m'avez
fait cette honneur
j'ai consacré toutes mes forces tous mes
instants
dans un moment difficile
à nous doter des outils de notre
redressement
ces dernières semaines nous n'avons pas
économisé notre énergie lancement d'un
média inauguration d'une académie de
formation qui porte le nom de Georges
Mondel figure de la Résistance figure
d'une droite des valeurs et des
convictions
un média qui porte le nom que lui avait
donné Philippe Seguin une certaine idée
cette certaine idée de la France que
porter notre famille politique
constitution d'un Shadow cabinet autour
d'Annie Genevard notre secrétaire
général que je salue
création valider ce matin par notre
conseil national d'un signe tant d'un
cercle de réflexion la France demain
présidé par Guillaume l'arrivée et par
Jean Leonetti
ce sont ces outils mes amis qui nous
permettront de mener la bataille des
idées oui les républicains vont
redevenir le parti des idées face à
l'hégémonie médiatique et culturelle de
l'extrême gauche la droite a le devoir
de se ressaisir du glaive de
l'intelligence la droite a le devoir de
sortir de ses confort et de ses routines
nous devons renouer avec l'innovation en
nous écartant plus que jamais de tous
les conformismes de la pensée
préfabriquée et des réflexes stériles de
communication les Français n'attendent
pas des slogans ils espèrent et ils
attendent des solutions face aux crises
qu'ils affrontent
face aux crises qu'ils affrontent ils
veulent plus des idées neuves que des
idées réchauffées ou paresseuses nous
avons le devoir de leur offrir des
solutions innovantes des idées fortes
bref de couper le robinet d'eau tiède le
devoir le devoir mes amis avec vous de
nous saisir de tous les grands enjeux
car rien de ce qui est français doit
nous être étranger on ne comprend la
plaine que du haut des sommets écrivez
le dramaturge Ipsen alors visons les
sommets ne nous interdisons aucune
ambition aucune audace aucun combat sur
chaque sujet sur chaque question la
droite doit se faire entendre elle doit
te faire entendre ces valeurs la voix de
l'autorité de la liberté de l'identité
jamais ces valeurs et l'enquête tout à
l'heure de Louis Harris en témoigné le
démontrer jamais ses valeurs n'ont été
au temple et visité par les Français et
pourtant jamais elles n'ont été aussi
absentes des couloirs du pouvoir nous
voulons les replacer au cœur de la vie
politique notre refondation nous ne
devons pas simplement et seulement la
conduire pour nous-mêmes naturellement
mais nous devons l'amener surtout pour
la France car la France a besoin d'une
droite forte courageuse conquérante
en me rétorquera
on me rétorquera que ce n'est pas bien
novateur que ce n'était plus dans l'air
du temps
à l'air du en même temps que d'être de
droite il y a 6 ans rappelez-vous
on nous disait que la gauche et la
droite n'existaient plus
que ces concepts étaient dépassés qu'il
devait être balayé
remplacer par un nouveau monde
merveilleux
on nous promettait un nouveau monde
d'experts de techniciens
nous avons aujourd'hui la plus banale
des technocraties
les Français ne veulent plus d'une
politique avec un peu de gauche un peu
de droite et au final beaucoup
d'immobilisme
le en même temps a failli car le en même
temps c'est l'impuissance c'est
l'absence d'idées c'est l'absence de
conviction c'est l'absence de valeur
nous l'avons bien vu avec la politique
migratoire du gouvernement alors que les
Français
disent clairement sans ambiguïté
qu'il refuse cette immigration de masse
qu'elle est source de chaos et qu'elle
doit être jugulée le gouvernement s'est
embourbé dans un projet inconsistant et
sans cesse repoussé
un projet incohérent qui voulait lutter
en même temps encore une fois contre
l'immigration et légale et en même temps
procéder à une régularisation massive
des clandestins
insupportables
insupportable double discours pendant ce
temps pendant ce temps 500 000 étrangers
sont entrés légalement sur notre
territoire en 2022 pendant ce temps le
taux d'expulsion de ces fameuses
obligations de quitter le territoire
français continue à se situer à des
niveaux ridiculement bas pendant ce
temps un quart des places de nos prisons
sont occupés par des étrangers en
situation régulière où irrégulière
pendant ce temps les arrivées de
migrants sur les côtes italienne ont été
quadruplées sur les premiers mois de
2023 au total
toujours plus d'arrivée toujours moins
d'expulsion toujours plus de délinquance
liés à l'immigration toujours moins
d'intégration ou d'assimilation mes amis
que de temps perdu
peu de temps perdu à jouer les
équilibristes la méthode du en même
temps nous a montré toutes ces limites
il faut donc et c'est une conclusion
évidente en changer
urgemment nous
avec vous aux républicains
nous voulons ouvrir un autre chemin
nous l'avons démontré avec les
propositions de loi que nous avons porté
fièrement avec Olivier marletz le
président de notre groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale et avec Bruno Retailleau
avec l'ensemble de nos parlementaires
sénateurs députés
en harmonie avec nos députés européens
chers François-Xavier cher Nadine
cherbrice
ces propositions sont à l'image de ce
que nous sommes et de ce que nous
voulons ce sont des propositions
sérieuses ce sont des propositions
courageuses ce sont des propositions
réalistes le sérieux le courage le
réalise oui ce sont des valeurs qui
veulent en révisant notre Constitution
par référendum redonner au peuple de
France la maîtrise de son destin
que ceux qui parlent de façon
impuissante sans cesse et toujours
nous écoute répondre à notre appel
l'appel du peuple l'appel de la réforme
de la Constitution pour retrouver le
cours de notre destin pour modifier par
référendum aujourd'hui ce qui bloque ce
qui entrave ce qui paralyse la destinée
de notre nation a choisi qui à l'accueil
qui elle souhaite et qui elle ne veut
plus sur son territoire
si les Français n'accordent plus de
crédit au discours politique et nous
l'avons vu tout à l'heure
s'ils accordent plus de crédit aux
formations politiques c'est parce qu'il
n'y voit plus qu'un tunnel de parole
sans consistance sans conséquence
tournée sur l'émotion du quotidien
sans regarder au loin
vers les sommets et l'avenir de notre
nation en leur montrant la voie d'une
politique qui regarde les réalités
telles qu'elles sont en leur montrant
tout à la fois la voix d'une politique
qui agit alors nous réhabiliterons la
parole publique nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire de se discrédit de
l'abstention du vote vers des formations
qui ne peuvent apporter que des impasses
à notre nation le courage la
responsabilité voilà deux vertus
cardinales pour la France et pour les
républicains
je veux pour la France une droite de
l'action et des solutions une droite
d'action qui se préoccupe du quotidien
tout en portant une vision voilà notre
bataille
oui nous devons parler du quotidien des
Français du quotidien des Français qui
ne parviennent plus à se loger du
quotidien des Français qui ne
parviennent plus à se nourrir du
quotidien des Français qui travaillent
sans être payés décemment du quotidien
des Français écrasés par l'inflation par
le prix de l'électricité du fioul des
carburants du quotidien des Français
étouffés par une fiscalité
confisque à toi
du quotidien des Français qui ne peuvent
plus se soigner partout et à côté de
chez eux confrontés à des urgences
saturées confrontés au désert médicaux
du quotidien des Français de ces
terribles ruraux de nos villes et de nos
campagnes trop souvent délaissés voir
abandonner car le quotidien des Français
ce sont hélas ces violences qui
empoisonnent qui polluent la vie de nos
compatriotes face à cette tourmente de
l'insécurité
l'État doit retrouver autorité
fermeté et force l'État doit de nouveau
se faire respecter
à contre-courant à contre-courant des
immondes slogans de l'extrême gauche
dégoulinant de haine
nous nous voulons dire que nous aimons
la police et que nous l'applaudissons
oui nous applaudissons nos forces de
l'ordre nos policiers nos gendarmes mais
aussi nos pompiers nos militaires nos
douaniers
tous ceux qui nous font l'honneur de
porter l'uniforme de la République
c'est uniforme tricolore doit être
sacrée il doit être intouchable oui nous
applaudissons tous ceux qui se
mobilisent chaque jour au péril souvent
de leur propre vie pour protéger les
Français pour défendre notre nation et
quelquefois pour la sauver dernier
rempart contre la barbarie
nous applaudissons aussi
ceux qui les rejoignent qu'il est
rejoignent par la bravoure ses citoyens
d'exception comme seul fut le calme si
notamment avec Henri
merci à nos héros il donne de la force
et du courage
tout le monde peut constater aujourd'hui
la flambée des violences
mille Français sont agressés chaque jour
sans policier ou gendarmes sont blessés
sont agressés chaque jour
600 cambriolages sont commis les
homicides et les tentatives d'homicides
ont doublé en disant les coups et
blessures volontaires que subissent nos
concitoyens
augmenter de 50% en disant
comment pouvons-nous accepter au-delà de
ces chiffres de ces statistiques que des
dealers
accordent désormais délaissés pour
entrer dans des quartiers de la
République comme nous l'avons vu encore
récemment à Marseille
comment pouvons-nous accepter comment
ceux qui nous dirige peuvent accepter
que la violence ce soit répandue jusque
dans ce sanctuaire que doit être l'école
de la République
oui le quotidien des Français
le quotidien des familles
et là encore cette valeur de la famille
elle est essentielle le quotidien de nos
familles c'est une école qui s'effrite
pour ne pas dire qui s'effondre sous les
coups de boutoirs d'une violence qui
contamine tout d'une défiance permanence
à l'autorité à l'autorité de la loi de
la règle à l'autorité du maître d'école
d'une violence qui prive trop d'élèves
de conditions d'enseignement dignes de
ce nom et conduit un affaiblissement
inédit de notre niveau scolaire
ayons ici
solennellement une pensée de soutien et
de fraternité pour tous les jeunes
Français
victimes de harcèlement scolaire
nous pensons à vous nous battons pour
vous nous battrons pour vous et nous
vous rendrons justice
l'école oui l'école doit devenir ce
sanctuaire intouchable un viable
et de tous les quotidiens le quotidien
de nos enfants doit être le plus sacré
je refuse le quotidien de la peur qui
est devenu celui de trop d'enfants nous
devons tolérer aucun des ordres dans nos
écoles et nous ne tolérons pas davantage
que les atteintes à la laïcité s'y
multiplient et fracture la cohésion
sociale nous nous opposerons fermement
au tic-tac de l'islamisme
l'État doit assumer ses responsabilités
nous le disons au ministre de
l'éducation nationale dont les
ambiguïtés coupables ne sont pas
acceptables nous le disons l'État doit
assumer ses responsabilités sans se
défausser le voile comme la voulu
Jacques Chirac mais aujourd'hui les
abats dans nos écoles
[Applaudissements]
les burkinis dans nos piscines ou sur
les plages sinon
la laïcité
pilier de notre République valeur portée
au départ par une gauche républicaine
derrière Clémenceau la laïcité ne peut
supporter le moindre à commandement
qu'il soit petit ou grand elle se
déforme partout toujours
aucune religion ne peut il ne doit
imposer ces dogmes à la République
nous ne laisserons pas
messieurs Piol et ses acolytes qu'ils
soient maire de Strasbourg de Bordeaux
ou d'ailleurs
abandonner la République aux
obscurantistes nous nous labandonnerons
pas et nous nous tiendrons fermement aux
côtés des Français
alors oui mes amis je veux rendre
hommage à ces Français qui traversent
avec tant de volonté
tant de dignité tant de courage souvent
humble
c'est quotidien difficile
il se battent chaque jour et malgré tout
maintiennent le cap de leur vie debout
ce courage nous oblige ils nous oblige à
chercher des voies pour améliorer leur
vie
nous devons être en mesure de dire aux
Français avec nous
votre vie sera plus simple plus digne
mieux protégée
nous devons même être en mesure de leur
dire avec nous
vous vivrez mieux
je veux que nous nous donnions un
objectif nouveau
inédit peut-être surprenant à leur des
statistiques de la comptabilité publique
je veux que nous nous donnions un
objectif
majeur à relever dans les années à venir
celui de l'augmentation de l'espérance
de la vie celui de l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
aujourd'hui
l'espérance de vie
source
la plus palpente la plus prégnante du
progrès depuis 50 ans
et stabilisé c'est déjà une inquiétude
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé à
reculer et l'espérance de vie marque
aussi des déséquilibres profonds dans
nos territoires peut-on accepter qu'on
vive aujourd'hui comme l'indiquer
l'Insee deux ans de moins dans nos zones
rurales que dans nos grandes cités
urbaines
en répondant
à répondant à tous les enjeux quotidiens
de nos compatriotes nous pouvons
poursuivre cet objectif ambitieux
derrière lequel se cache des
problématiques majeures des
problématiques de santé bien sûr des
problématiques de prise en charge des
bruits fragiles de nos aînés comme de
nos enfants qu'il faut protéger avec ce
défi de la dépendance qui est devant
nous
mais également des problématiques
d'inégalités entre nos territoires
notamment pour l'accès aux soins aux
services publics
cet objectif de l'espérance de vie nous
invite à placer notre confiance dans le
progrès scientifique
ne cédons pas aux sirènes du repli
demeurant ce peuple audacieux qu'aucun
défi n'est frais ne soyons pas tétanisés
notamment devant l'émergence de
l'intelligence artificielle mais
redonnons-nous résolument les moyens
d'être à nouveau des pionniers ne
passons pas à côté des défis de la
science des défis du progrès technique
des défis de la recherche
ce sont les défis de notre siècle nous
devons faire notamment de notre siècle
celui de la victoire contre les cancers
ce sont de telles objectifs qui doivent
guider notre action
aucune action n'est trop grande car nous
avons le devoir et l'exigence de
l'espérance notre droite c'est une
droite qui ne se résigne pas au déclin
et au désordre c'est une droite des
idées qui ne délaisse aucun enjeu qui ne
s'interdit aucun combat c'est une droite
qui s'appuie fermement sur ses valeurs
d'ordre d'autorité
d'identité de liberté
une droite qui veut redresser la France
en reconstruisant l'état une droite au
service du quotidien de notre peuple et
au service du rayonnement de notre
nation voilà la vision que la droite
d'opportunité avec humanité pour nourrir
l'espérance nous devons être capables de
parler aussi bien aux Français de la
semaine que du siècle qui s'annonce et
pour cela mes amis pour que les Français
puissent vivre dans la dignité dans la
sérénité pour qu'il conserve un esprit
d'audace et de conquête la Florence doit
être forte libre indépendante souveraine
comme nous l'a appris le général de
Gaulle
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de peuple
libre dans une nation qui ne l'est pas
la liberté
c'est la première des trois vertus de
notre devise républicaine ça doit être
aussi la première des valeurs de la
droite
elle est indissociable de l'autorité car
il ne peut y avoir de liberté dans le
désordre et le chaos elle est
indissociable de l'identité car il n'y a
pas de liberté dans l'oubli de soi-même
nous sommes ce parti de la liberté qui
veut desserrer les trop nombreux carcans
qui nous en serre et qui pèse lourdement
trop lourdement tellement lourdement sur
les Français le carcan de la fiscalité
et le carcan de la bureaucratie je veux
je veux demain une droite de la baisse
des impôts
il nous faut il nous faut en finir avec
les dérives d'une fiscalité
écrasante il nous faut en finir avec les
dérives de nos finances publiques
Gérard le disait il y a quelques
instants chaque année nous sommes en
finale de la Coupe du Monde des impôts
avec des prélèvements obligatoires qui
ont dépassé les 45% et demi de notre
richesse nationale
nous sommes les finalistes de la Coupe
du Monde des dépenses publiques avec des
dépenses publiques qui atteignent plus
de 58% de notre richesse nationale et
oui certains
osent dénoncer une forme de libéralisme
qu'est-ce que ça serait si on était plus
haut alors oui
notre état
notre état est devenu une machine
impotente et impuissante incarnez trop
souvent par des services publics devenus
défaillants malgré le dévouement la
compétence et l'engagement de nos
fonctionnaires que je salue de nos
enseignants de nos soignants de nos
magistrats de nos policiers de nos
gendarmes
mais pour autant l'école l'hôpital la
justice aujourd'hui
ne sont plus dignes de la conscience des
Français
il nous faut entendre il nous faut
entendre la colère du contribuable
canard ras-le-bol de financer à fond
perdu le déclin de notre nation
oui je veux une droite de la baisse des
impôts oui je veux une droite de l'ordre
dans nos comptes publics comment
regarder avec confiance vers demain
quand la dette de la France dépasse les
3000 milliards d'euros que en regardait
avec confiance l'avenir quand la France
en 2024 sera le seul pays d'Europe à
connaître un déficit public supérieur à
3%. ce n'est pas moi qui le dit mais un
commissaire européen que nous avons
rencontré avec Michel Barnier et
François-Xavier mercredi à Strasbourg en
remettant de l'ordre dans nos comptes
nous redonnerons à la France sa dignité
et sa crédibilité
la France ne peut donner des leçons de
plus en plus déplacées à l'Europe et à
la terre entière en continuant à vivre à
crédit un état mieux géré c'est un état
plus efficace un état qui accompagne et
simplifie la vie des Français alors
qu'aujourd'hui il accomplit en
permanence ou la déesse trop souvent
nous sommes et nous devons être encore
plus
cette famille de la liberté qui veut
mettre fin à l'hystérie des normes qui
s'accumule et viennent régenter le
moindre micro détails de nos vies
c'est énorme forgée par quelques
technocrates déconnectées du bon sens et
de toute réalité
c'est des feux zan DPE
ces acronymes décrivent tout simplement
une atteinte à nos droits individuels et
un retour inédit sur les acquis de la
décentralisation
demain si on suit cette logique celle
que dénoncer le brillant rapport du
sénateur Philippe Tabarro celle
qui est portée par la proposition de loi
de nos sénateurs bientôt en débat à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le zéro
artificialisation nette celle sur ses
diagnostics qui vont faire sortir du
marché dès l'année prochaine du logement
600 000 personnes et qui vont fragiliser
encore un peu plus le droit à la
propriété et la liberté individuelle de
disposer de ce lieu où l'on peut et où
l'on doit vivre ces mesures
fruit de bobos déconnecté
prépare un mouvement des gilets jaunes
puissant vis
à ceux qui nous gouvernent d'entendre la
colère qui gronde et qui monte
oui nous ne pouvons plus supporter
aujourd'hui tous ces agréments toutes
ces autorisations toutes ces dérogations
qu'il faut obtenir pour entreprendre
innover construire bâtir réaliser
investir bref vivre
nous devons nous devons mes amis abattre
la tyrannie du CERFA
nous devons libérer la France de la
bureaucratie oui nous sommes ce parti de
la liberté
qui regarde les Français comme des
citoyens libres et responsables
digne de confiance capable de mener
souverainement leur destin
plus la liberté de notre peuple sera
grande et plus la liberté de notre
nation le sera aussi plus elle sera
forte et plus nos libertés seront
garanties
c'est aussi pour cela que nous devons
nous doter d'une armée puissante capable
de mener des conflits de haute intensité
de se projeter sur les théâtres
d'opérations extérieures qui nous
éviterons les débats et les recules tels
que nous les connaissons sur le
continent africain dont le lien avec la
France était pourtant si puissant si
fort et qui est en train d'être rompu de
façon extraordinairement dangereuse dans
un continent et avec un continent chargé
d'enjeux pour l'Europe et pour la France
c'est pour cela
que nous avons besoin
de défendre l'outil de dissuasion
nucléaire voulu par le général de Gaulle
qui nous a donné ce statut
ce statut de grande puissance
quand nous compris nous devons voir
altérer
c'est pourquoi nous ne devons pas
abandonner l'excellence de notre réseau
diplomatique
la voie de la France doit être toujours
portée et en 30 ans du et respecté
si la France devenait à se taire
le monde est singulièrement l'Europe
ils perdrait une part de leur âme
certaines disent que les nations sont
dépassées
nous affirmons résolument le contraire
face aux crises que nous traversons
les nations sont plus essentielles que
jamais
et dans ce domaine quel vertige quand on
regarde le fossé qui s'est creusé entre
la gauche devenue l'extrême gauche et la
nation
quel vertige de voir cette gauche
convertie au mélenchonisme intégral à
toutes les idéologies de la dissolution
nous nous voulons conserver ce que la
France a forgé au cours des siècles eux
ils en contestent le moindre fragment de
notre île à notre drapeau de notre
langue à notre histoire
il nous refuse jusqu'au droit à la
fierté d'être Français
l'extrême gauche cherche toujours à tout
abaisser à tout salir à tout
déconstruire rien de ce qui est la
France leur convient ils n'auront jamais
de repos tant que tout ne sera pas
parfaitement repeint au sombre couleur
de leur idéologie
l'extrême gauche voilà l'ennemi voilà
l'ennemi de la France et de la
République
nous ne les laisserons pas faire et avec
nous il n'y aura pas de walkistan en
France il y aura pas de walkistan en
lieu et place de la France millénaire
nous nous n'avons pas honte de la France
nous l'aimons je l'aime passionnément
nous aimons et nous en sommes fiers elle
est la condition de notre existence
comme peuple souverain car pour être un
peuple selon la formule de Renan il faut
avoir fait de grandes choses ensemble et
vouloir en faire encore le patriotisme
au fond
porte une grande leçon d'humilité
une grande leçon d'humilité devant tout
ce qui nous a été donné transmis et
devant tout ce qu'il nous appartient de
poursuivre n'ayons pas peur de nous
enraciner dans nos terres et notre
histoire pouvoir loin pour être à la
hauteur des enjeux du monde plantons nos
pieds fermement dans cette terre de
France qui est la nôtre portant notre
regard aussi loin un avant quand
nous-mêmes malgré leur importance les
statistiques de la comptabilité publique
ne peuvent être notre seul horizon
entre cap ce sont les Français notre cap
c'est la France et la France n'est pas
une hypothèse ou un théorème mais une
réalité charnelle passionnelle inscrit
dans les sons de sa langue dans les
gloires de son passé dans les odeurs de
sa terre dans les visages de son peuple
dans les lumières de ces paysages nous
sommes tous les enfants de nos villages
de nos usines de nos routes de nos
villes de nos champs
les enfants de la Méditerranée les
enfants de l'océan des océans avec nos
outre-mer de nos montagnes de nos
plaines de nos îles bref les enfants de
la Patrie la France est de 1000 ans
d'histoire la France et le baptême de
Clovis ces gendarmes l'héritage du
millénaire capétien la France et la
Révolution française la glorieuse épopée
napoléonienne c'est la République debout
celle d'un peuple libre celle de Jules
Ferry de Clémenceau de Simone Veil c'est
la résistance
ceux des résistants du plateau des
Glières des marins de l'île de Sein des
Compagnons de la Libération derrière le
général oui mes chers amis mes chers
compagnons notre responsabilité est
immense notre pays sortira bientôt nous
vous en faisons la promesse d'une longue
trop longue période de confusion et
d'inaction
menacée
menacé par des impossures et des
démagogies qui ne résoudront rien et
alors que notre pays fait face à des
défis gigantesques nous devons ouvrir ce
chemin d'espérance nous n'avons pas le
droit de nous dérober oui nous garderons
le cap du redressement de l'ordre dans
nos rues comme dans nos finances dans la
liberté dans nos entreprises comme dans
nos vies et de l'identité aimer affirmer
en étant fermement et fièrement
enraciné dans ce qu'a été notre pays
tout en étant pleinement ancré dans les
réalités quotidiennes nous porterons une
vision pour demain pour la France de
2030 pour celle de 2100 les Français
attendent de leurs hommes publics cette
vision ils attendent de nous que les que
la politique que la parole publique
cesse d'être une start-up de
communication pour devenir redevenir
ce qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû cesser
d'être c'est à dire l'antichambre de
notre avenir la fabrique de la France de
demain chers Xavier toi qui a porté ce
message de fabrique merci d'être là pour
répondre
à la défiance grandissante des Français
vis-à-vis de la politique
le seul chemin de la crédibilité c'est
de porter une vision le seul chemin de
la crédibilité c'est de leur offrir des
politiques sérieuses efficaces
solidement arrimé au réel et pourtant un
souffle d'espérance et d'ambition
l'ambition d'une France millénaire qui
avance sans oublier sans se renier le
premier de nos devoirs c'est de
convaincre les Français de croire en la
France de croire à nouveau en eux-mêmes
en leur montrant d'abord que nous nous
croyons toujours
profondément
passionnément en la France en son club
et que nous nous ne cesserons jamais je
dis bien jamais de porter cette
conviction nous ne nous laisserons pas
nous ne laisserons pas la France restait
sur le bas-côté du 21 siècle et assister
à la marche du monde en spectatrice cela
ne serait pas digne d'elle cela ne
serait pas digne de nous oui mes amis la
France continue et la France continuera
en acceptant de nous refonder en
retrouvant la voix d'une droite d'ordre
et de liberté de progrès et d'identité
nous continuerons de nous battre pour
notre pays c'est ce chemin que nous
ouvrons aujourd'hui et au bout de ce
chemin je vous en fais la promesse
solennelle il y a la victoire la
victoire pour la droite la victoire pour
la France notre histoire notre gloriase
histoire n'est pas finie l'histoire de
la droite n'est pas finie et l'histoire
de la France n'est certainement pas fini
nous ne nous résignerons pas nous ne
renoncerons pas nous ne capitulerons pas
nous sommes là toujours là et nous nous
battrons oui nous nous battrons encore
et toujours pour que vive les
républicains pour que vive la république
et pour que vit la France
[Applaudissements]
notre président des républicains